this isn't just an upgrade it's a
breakthrough
a new imac with an m1 chip redesigned
for the first time in years
check new ipad pro with stuff that
apple's really excited about
check a 29 tracker that can help you
find your lost bag or keys
check again new apple tv remote that
isn't horrible
seems like it check a new purple iphone
for someone check update to apple's
greatest product
ever ted lasso check he'll be back in
july
okay it was a pretty packed apple
product infomercial there has never been
a more exciting time for the mac
i mean apple's spring virtual event i
watched it all comfortably from right
here
which means i haven't actually touched
these products in a room full of tech
journalists
a practice i hope never returns post
pandemic
still i've got lots of thoughts on this
new stuff let's break it all down
from smallest product to largest
number one air tax no these aren't
mentos
here's how apple's new lost item
trackers work you attach these to things
you often lose
keys wallet i don't know your stuffed
bunny
then they use bluetooth and ultra
wideband technology to report to your
iphone
so if you can't find them you open the
find my app on your iphone
and see if they're plotted on the map a
feature called precision tracking will
guide you to the object if it's in close
proximity
guiding you right to your air tag and if
you can't see it you can sound an alarm
so you can hear it
[Music]
this is an entirely new product category
for apple but it's not an entirely new
idea
companies like tile have made very
similar devices
air tags will be available for 29 on
april 30th
engraving is free number two apple tv 4k
there's only one super exciting thing
about this if you've had an older apple
tv
it has a new remote that doesn't
completely suck we completely redesigned
it with new functionality and controls
the new siri remote is bigger and gets
rid of that frustrating touch pad
and you can tell which way is up and
which way is down
the actual apple tv that you hook up to
your tv looks the same
but it promises better hdr playback with
a new a12 bionic chip
but honestly this apple tv is a hard
sell for anyone looking for a connected
streaming device
boxes from roku and amazon cost far less
the new apple tv starts at 179 the new
siri remote is sold separately for 59
and then there's the ipad pro for those
who consider themselves
pros and by that i mean someone who has
no problem spending over
800 on a tablet which still doesn't
include the 119
pencil or the base 179 keyboard folio
the upgrades here are all about speed
apple's put the m1 chip in both of those
that's the same chip that's in
the new max
yeah apple went super dramatic about it
for some reason
both also have faster thunderbolt usbc
ports and are available with 5g
for the larger 12.9 inch model the big
news was its fancy liquid
retina xdr display which apple says
this is the display you have to see to
believe
i cannot see it for myself right now
apple i just cannot
the coolest new ipad pro feature is
called center stage
when you're video calling the ultra wide
front camera will pan to you in the
frame
and widen if someone else jumps in okay
it's a trick already done on facebook's
portal and other devices
what we didn't get a new ipad mini yes
people still like the ipad mini like my
editor
and my colleague who are trying mini
tiers right now
the new 11 inch ipad pro starts at 7.99
the 12.9 inch at 10.99
as in 1099 both will ship in the second
half of may
finally the product i'm most excited
about here a new 24 inch imac
apple's lower end desktop hasn't had a
new look since 2012
but now it has an entirely new design
and comes with your choice of seven
colors
plus it also gets the new m1 chip which
allows it to be so
thin the 24 inch screen has a 4.5 k
retina display and the webcam has been
updated with a better sensor
it's the best camera we've ever put in a
mac
yeah well the bar is pretty low for that
apple since this is the footage from the
new macbook pro
the new imac has a keyboard upgrade
option with a built-in touch id
fingerprint sensor
and the magic mouse comes in matching
colors so many colors
it's like lots of colors the imac will
start at 12.99
and will also ship in the second half of
may we'll have reviews of these in the
coming weeks
in the meantime i'll be here trying to
approximate the size of air tags
with candies let's put this out
somewhere i actually don't like my toes